walk right here shut the fuck up get
right over here
[Music]
[Music]
let's take a look
oh
um
okay
[Music]
turn around turn around turn around do
not face me turn around
turn around walk right here walk right
here shut the fuck up get ready turn
around i don't give a fuck
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
get out of the fucking cars
[Music]
shut the fuck up get right over here i
don't give a fuck who you want get on
your goddamn knees
[Music]
okay
[Music]
how many people in the car
get out of the car
get out of the car
get out of the car right now
hands up in the air
right now
turn around turn around turn around do
not face me turn around
just walk right here walk right here
shut the fuck up get right over here i
don't give a fuck who you are get on
your knees
and you'll listen to me when i tell you
to get on your knees
claire there
you used to work for miami-dade
man
stand there
okay
when it comes to
be quiet don't say another word you hear
me
all right
everything's cool sorry man
of course of course we gotta check this
car first there's there's guns radios
and all kinds of shit
what's up man what's going on i see you
in a bit yeah
well that wasn't known when he passed me
no he's drunk
did you turn that did you turn that on
or it was on
but
son of a bitch
casey do you have a
let's do this by the books do you happen
to have a miranda card
thank you
boss what's your first name
don
don donovan donovan that's your first
name yes okay
don't say anything just yet understand
me
you know how this goes
i don't want to be quiet before i ask
you any questions you must understand
your rights
you have the right to remain silent
anything you say can be used against you
in court you have the right to talk to a
lawyer for advice before we ask you any
questions you have a right to have a
lawyer with you during questioning
if you cannot afford a lawyer one will
be appointed for you before any
questioning it if you wish
if you decide to answer questions now
without a lawyer present you have the
right to stop answering at any time
do you understand each other these
rights i've explained to you i get it
rather
with these rights in mind do you wish to
talk to me now i'm not saying okay
i feel you're impaired
me yeah
no okay are you willing to perform field
sobriety i just say spill my suspicion
you drink ready
no okay
is this an agency vehicle yes sir
this is his agency car
this is his agency car
conductor
i just asked him around the time i just
got here
um
so she doesn't want to talk he refuses
to feel sobriety exercises
absolutely he's fucked up
all right
let's thank you it is what it is all
right i will notify
what we are doing do you want a rotation
or what are we going to do with the car
we're going to do rotation okay but
everything
that's agency related we need to take
the store because i don't want to be
responsible for
in cars firearms
yep uh
yeah if we can ask if we can do them
solid and let them know that they got
all this shit here if they have somebody
local they can come and pick it up
so that
i mean i don't mind
doing the property receipt that's not
the reason i'm just saying
scott
i don't even know what to do yet
it was your guy he was andy i clocked
him at 107.
i got him up to 111. i know he saw my
lights all right
on the first two points
okay
he never slowed down so
i was directly behind him and he still
kept going he was waiting
in and out of traffic
and he's not on duty so he shouldn't be
running code
well he didn't have those lights were
not turned on no no those lights weren't
on when he went he passed me and
if they were on now i couldn't see them
because they weren't facing me anyway
this one's going to like fell down
anyways
yeah that yeah you can barely see here
and
the visor lights were not on
when he passed me so i don't know if he
no that definitely no that wasn't it's
like falling down
all right
get my uh tell me what you want me to
take all this stuff or what do you want
to do it
okay let me grab some stuff to put it
all in
original speed was 107.
he got so far away from me
after i turned on my lights and i
couldn't get a
speed once i got close enough
when he was still fleeing it was 111.
that was the top speed that i was able
to record
he was running running for me
where i was at
i was there
everything's all right everything's okay
let me get some stuff to bag all that
stuff
hang on tight box i'm going to talk with
you in just a second okay
andy if you want to just toss whatever
you
whatever you get here's a box you can
toss all his stuff okay that we need to
take i'm going to take him to the roth
if if you just want to drop it off or
well how can i help you yeah yeah
so i'll leave this here so you have
somewhere to put everything i think said
everything like agency
i mean i was right there with you guys
fucking bro
arresting a cop jesus fucking christ
all right sorry i'm gonna head out i
gave him something to put all the stuff
in we'll figure out the is he uh
supervisor
who i can contact so that we can get his
stuff yeah
yeah let me ask him that's not that's
not an incriminating question because he
said he didn't want to talk to me
but
donovan
i'm trying to get all your stuff to
somebody safe uh
can we contact your immediate supervisor
yeah i do
can we contact your immediate supervisor
that's right okay
we don't want to leave all your shit
here man we wouldn't want to put it into
property want to see if we can get it to
a supervisor okay right from the your
supervisor to keep it under wraps
so
do you happen to have his name a phone
number if you have it
have you have my number there i got your
phone right here yeah
yep right there
i don't know how to open this thing up
three one five three one five yes sir
seven seven
seven seven seven seven
seven seven nine
if you call zach that's my partner
cst cruz
what's up
no
it's diego
going to be sergeant cruz sergeant diego
cruz yes sir
what unit do you work for i was like
you already invoked your right to remain
silent so i'm not going to ask you any
questions bro though man
bro
you you this is not the highlight of my
day
i know uh bro i'm sorry brother but yep
don't say anything else
i got it for you serge
sergeant diego cruz
time 11 and wrong with one stuff to get
you out
wow